rock n roll I'm ready hall of fame hey
what's happening thanks for tuning in to
another episode of what to be talked
this episode is brought to you by my
fantastic motorcycle sponsor el cajon
Harley do not buy a motorcycle anywhere
else el cajon Harley is where it's at
Southern California's best
harley-davidson dealer obviously in my
eyes and yours too if you go down there
you'll find out why super cool people
fantastic selection of motorcycles they
got all the 2017 touring bikes in there
right now with the new engine the
Milwaukee eight they also will not be
beat on their tire prices go see them on
that and they've got a scary movie night
coming up I think it's maybe tomorrow
night go to El Cajon Harley calm and
find out everything about him hit up
Greg Riley down there get yourself a
bike and also follow him on Instagram
and Twitter alright how are you buddy
spicer I'm good I'm glad to be here
welcome back man you but you're like a
Mad Max the road warrior but like the
comedy version you like strapped on the
hood of a car with the microphone just
like jokes it's another road a lot it's
funny because I I realized a couple days
ago brenton and I'd went and did fresno
and and I came home and I was like
life's pretty [ __ ] good right now
yeah you know it's it's so different
traveling as a comedian than it was with
the band because I'm really like
punctual and as for as rock and roll as
I am I always show up on time and [ __ ]
and I'm pretty responsible instead of I
don't know why I got that from my mama
yes but the point is when you're
traveling with three four guys or five
and you're down in lobby calls at 6am
and here comes the guy just [ __ ] it's
yeah right it's just like and then it
comes out it's always a is the worst one
I hate ever when they got a sorry I'm
late dude traffic yeah I just [ __ ] I
I hate you when you say that it does
traffic every [ __ ] day
you tried to leave and like a dumb time
you show up late and then i'm just like
[ __ ] you know so it's great to travel
around and new york city's been really
i'm going back in two weeks i mean just
say you're mad at me for being two
minutes late today you don't have to do
a whole story minutes that's like you
know what I'm talking about that it's
just kind of like [ __ ] it's better to
travel alone sure well I don't want to
pile on any one specific and maybe this
wasn't the case for you with bands but
for me when I was running track like
collegiately in a little post
collegiately it was always the worst
person who was late yeah already
borderline hey yeah it's like that dude
normal alternate on this relay don't
need you and you're holding us up like
get out of here yeah like you know what
you're about to get kicked out of the
band drummer like don't you know we have
Travis waiting for it it was crazy man
you know one thing I it's funny because
i was in Edmonton and had such a bummer
time that there was I was sitting there
and I was like at damn that sucked and
then as I got home I was realizing as
much as that sucked it doesn't come
close to doing construction sure so it
really all came into frame of mind of
like and Emily talking good right now
cuz uh it's a good couple months just
let me again around December when the
calendars [ __ ] empty I'm going what
the [ __ ] yeah you know it's got bigs up
ups and downs and right now it's it's
pretty good it's up and some good
weekend I'm pretty [ __ ] simple if I
just have a good weekend booked every
month then I'm like okay I'm working and
I can go out and work this hour and then
I'm gonna start doing some more store
one hour nights not you know yeah and
stuff like that but uh and like I said
New York's just been a [ __ ] killer
man yeah awesome yeah what do you been
doing a lot of writing
oh I'm recording my next album November
15th in San Diego oh it was dad that's
again sochi like recording there well
I've only done it once and I liked it a
lot right this second the beauty of it
for me is it's very low risk and I'm
very at home on the stage right like I'd
love to go to comedy works in Denver and
do a weekend or some like that and get
four shows under my belt but I wouldn't
want to do that like right now for the
recording having never performed there
or something you know what I mean I
think that gives it a [ __ ] you know
you you you you get [ __ ] like all
right I got a [ __ ] I think if you're
too comfortable sometimes you punch in a
little bit like I got this you know what
I mean maybe where have your [ __ ] off
a little bit man you're like oh [ __ ] I
gotta get it you know yeah I mean it
could be naive of me but I like the idea
like the first one was titled moment in
time my first album because I wanted it
to be specifically that like this is
this album this day this time it is
capturing that live moment and I had a
notable name stand-up comedian be like
look I really admire what you did for
your album that's cool like one take one
show one whatever he's like but I'll be
honest everybody thinks that's how my
album was recorded too yeah and mine was
six shows yeah be together but at this
you know at a beautiful club and
whatever and I'm like that's a good
point but I still like the idea of what
where I am in my career and what I'm
puttin out like the authenticity of that
it's almost like a very well-made
bootleg yeah like my hand made serious
yeah Hunter success self-made handmade
[ __ ] you know ain't no one gonna do
that's the thing people sit around all
their life and wait for somebody to do
it form and it's like why in this day
and age of of course you want Comedy
Central of course you want [ __ ] you
know Netflix or C so or whatever to to
put your [ __ ] out but if they don't are
you not gonna do something you know
right and I have a you know I'm
fortunate to have a fan base and an
audience that wants to hear stuff that
can't see me in LA and I'm not on the
road enough to say she ate that need so
unless that's for me recording there is
also a risk financially where it costs
money you know I'm getting a nice good
recording in but I'm not
taking a theater I'm not so it works out
where like if worst-case scenario i go
down there on the 15th in this set just
is awful yeah i don't really sit no harm
no foul yeah you know what it means not
another day uh but I'm excited for it
hopefully uh hopefully it all comes
together I lost you said like one good
weekend a month is all you need kind of
things up on the same weekend this is
two months ago now on the same weekend I
lost two weekends in one thursday night
headlining spot that I had lined up as
like prep yeah Beth and I was just like
son of a [ __ ] yeah that's [ __ ] you
know I always look at that as I go
here's how I'm going to pay rent and eat
yeah like maybe you're touring with the
headliner night headliner gets a TV show
or something and then your whole [ __ ]
I was talking to Brenton about this
awesome you're like wow I just not on
the road at all I mean you get forced to
headline when you maybe maybe or not you
know yeah you can headline but are your
headliner I always say this now I'm not
a headliner but it's it's uh it's forced
you're forced into it and which makes
you start writing and working harder and
stuff but I never go out there no yeah
I'm a headliner now that's [ __ ]
lunacy man you know lady the guy that
will say you are a headliner I will be
the guy that will say that for you but I
also will say and hopefully don't get
pissed at me after the show your name on
average marquee anywhere a medicine man
[ __ ] will not sell it out no but that
doesn't mean you're not a headliner that
just means that you haven't been on a
reality TV show you know don't get me
wrong there are named comics that our
headliners are names that have been on a
shitty reality TV show but that's the
weird thing about comedy right now yeah
like you can be a killer headliner but
you weren't on uh the best leather chair
in America what I'm looking at a chair
like that and so it won't sell a room
you need to grind out like 5-10 years on
the road doing this [ __ ] yeah man you
know it's like it's all it's all
delusional too you know you gotta have
like like you get a hundred thousand
listeners on your podcast and you go
what [ __ ] man that's got to be good for
at least a hundred seats in every club
and then you go out there and
where is everyone and then it's just a
sea of [ __ ] excuses on Twitter dude
sorry next time and do do do do do do do
do to make an excuse over the next day
will you come in November yeah we say
that I've said that a million times I
think people do that because they feel
guilty sure and they want to act like
day and it's like really you you favor
every tweet I do every two minutes but
then I mysteriously for six weeks she
didn't realize is coming to Denver we
might have talked about this it's it's
been a while so i think i can say it
again um I do feel like what I love
doing shows like this actually started a
new podcast cuz i'm addicted to this
[ __ ] um I do think there's something
to be said about people get their
content from this right like it's like
they want to go see you live au
universal you they want to go see a
comedian live but at the end of the day
it's likely if they don't make it out
whatever but they know they're getting
this other content like you're you're
getting you know one or two episodes of
Dean Del Rey oh you're just a guest on
church also that's three awesome [ __ ]
hours of content they're getting so it's
not as if they don't see you live
they're not going to be able to see
Empire Strikes Back I find that the East
Coast listeners of this podcast are way
more loyal than the west coast it's
really wild like I do the stand and I'll
do the standing like 15 shows every show
there's people there from the podcast
listeners which is awesome man and it's
way harder there it's like cold out and
I gotta train it there or or they work
two [ __ ] jobs to pay their rent and
they come at the midnight show you know
like [ __ ] you know where I think
maybe California like I'll catch him
next time you know or whatever but East
Coast men it's been [ __ ] good out
there man as far as podcast and I felt
East East Coast was a little slow at
first on podcasting now everybody's got
one going out there and stuff but it was
a slow a slow train out there I wonder
if just the population density in New
York maybe helps with that guy like here
someone's like dude i love you i love
you
show I live in LA when can I see you
live la's like brea right now yeah and
that's a three hour [ __ ] drive at six
o'clock right that's not an hour train
ride from Coney that's a
three-and-a-half-hour like you're in
traffic just like okay which by the way
if you want to see me at the store next
tuesday i'm going to be running an hour
in the belly room 8 p.m. and Joey Diaz
is on that and another secret guess so
and brenton is going to be on there I
thought Brendan was gonna be a secret
gasps out the secret so quickly yeah all
right okay let's get into so also
Brenton is I just hear ya hasn't said
anything but that's why we keep we keep
looking at him and saying his name all
but yeah okay so let's keep talking
Brenton his brother the puck talking
about Brendan so much we gotta rock and
roll hall of fame nominees had just came
out last week he's truly an honor by the
way yeah good about it I put out that
kazoo kazoo playing with my
four-year-old yeah because is that that
guy from kazoo or Gazoo that was it what
was that guy from from Bugs Bunny I'm
Gazoo the greatest the alien guy Martian
Marvin the Martian yeah now it was like
cuz you don't know there's no way in
[ __ ] hell line I know okay so i was
on Sirius radio last week with Eddie
trunk and he the day these came down and
I love Eddie but boy did we but heads on
cuz Eddie is strictly Eddie trunk is
strictly rock yep which is a trip to me
because I think that like after a while
I feel like you kind of hit a ceiling
you need to kind of like your mind needs
different moods and variations you know
as the day goes on sure I might wake up
with iron maiden number the Beast but by
the afternoon i might go earth wind fire
so I can't just sit in my house like Ron
you're not i mean i mean i would go
crazy i think but i kinda get i kind of
get it is the rock and roll hall of fame
yeah oh no i think they
I know he doesn't care about he he
thinks they're rock and roll everyone in
this he's not betting heads on who
should who shouldn't be nominated he was
just like I don't really get my craft
work I put on kraftwerk I was like are
you kidding me kraftwerk dude i SAT
front row i thought it was [ __ ]
amazing he goes I never listened to put
him on he's like all right get rid of
that which is how I used to be in like
junior high yeah I'd be like all [ __ ]
up man metal you know so let's look at
some of the nominees bad brains of
course is I mean to me bad brains what I
think whenever a band is one hundred
percent groundbreaking in their own way
they should be a you know where they
started something and Eddie trunk
thought this too he thought if you were
the band that influenced a hundred bands
you're in automatically right that's
stupid if a band that you influenced is
in before you you know because without
you there's no disband yeah yeah so a
bad brain so you hipped him yeah I was
actually surprised I'm not as hip to the
rock and roll hall of fame who's already
a member like I was surprised we weren't
in like I don't quite know how this list
is that there are a couple on this list
of nominees that I was like oh weird
okay yeah but it makes total sense but
it also i mean i guess the reason why
they're not in is i don't know how many
platinum records they have yeah well you
know we were talking about this a course
part of the jive of the rock and roll
hall of fame is it is a business and
they need to sell tickets to get people
in there so then you're gonna like well
wait a minute man how the [ __ ] is
such-and-such not in here and they go
you know in the secret committee behind
the committee they're going like look we
need to get twenty eight dollars a head
all day long and you know such-and-such
isn't gonna you know draw tickety just
like comedy yeah you're not gonna go see
an outfit that Warren bites you know
Gary Numan let's say to me Gary Numan is
[ __ ] iconic you and I would and we'd
be the only ones in there
so about eight and everyone else would
just be looking at the same Elton John
coat that everyone I mean go to the
wrong yeah we love Don but we'd like
rights like okay there's Elton saying
there's Kurt Cobain's guitar and [ __ ]
sweater and and there's Eddie Vedder
letters [ __ ] brown corduroy jacket
now and get that right but also stuff
that stops me in the tracks is uh you
know stuff that you seen you're going
like whoa man like to me kraftwerk it's
just like this just I mean there is just
no electronica rock you know music
without these guys yeah you know what's
the band that where's the [ __ ] hell
what do they got punked dad [ __ ] yeah I
always forget that there's no def punk
yeah you know what I mean there's none
of that so anyway bad brains and I'm not
gonna sit here and pretend like I know
all kinds of bad brains but one sonic
sonic that show what's his name did the
sonic highway oh yeah yeah once that was
they did the DC and they were doing all
the punk rock and stuff of DC and you
really see in Bad Brains how
groundbreaking and [ __ ] you're just
gonna like I mean come on yeah yeah that
I mean I mean look how great they look
too I couldn't see Bad Brains you're
going like oh yeah was you know those
guys [ __ ] look like just [ __ ]
badass yeah they're gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] up
yeah Chaka Khan I don't see that to me
Chaka Khan I mean of course cool disco
era huge and stuff but that's where I
feel like I think they should have
called it the music I think there's a
few people like I love the Beastie Boys
yeah that's not a role oh yeah but the
beastie boys should be in there no no I
think it should be and I just think it's
like a misnomer I think this poem of
this it's like she's great but like yeah
but I mean like I I don't know I could
be talking out my ass but because I
didn't do the research on Chaka Khan and
I and I know you know she is obviously
epic and stuff but did she write her own
songs how many how many hits did she do
you know all that stuff I don't know the
criteria for it and then she
which I didn't really know this but
they've been on the ballot every [ __ ]
time and haven't made it anything like
they are well that's now Rogers who okay
now Rogers is like one of the most
famous producers but just put them in as
the producer that's a heavy and I were
saying you know like we're trying to get
abandoned you know that like 11 times
yeah and Iron Maiden's not in here yeah
or Judas Priest yeah they're never gonna
let metal bands in like you know it's
just like they're so anti metal I think
they'll get there they will be like in
10 or 20 years when people look back on
metal the way movie fans are moving or
and Ed intellectual members of the film
critic Pratt's are now looking at horror
and action movies yeah and I have a
Karama comedy yet they're starting to
come around on that other stuff and I
think you'll see metal seem that same
appreciation from like the the highbrow
critic well the Exorcist is one of the
best films i've ever seen and i wouldn't
even call that a horror film it's just
more of like or you know like it's just
so real to me up you know all right
Depeche Mode [ __ ] yeah what a gram in
video first of all the 80s you look at
the 80s and it's straight Depeche Mode
you know and then you look at like then
late 80s and early 90s punk scene and so
much of it is like it might seem weird
to people that aren't familiar with the
music but like so much you're talking
about influences coming out of what
Depeche Mode and bands like that we're
doing oh absolutely eps now this guy
slam dunk ELO yeah i mean you know come
on this guy just sold out three nights
at the bowl yeah in 2016 you didn't walk
down a street people yo yo what's that
you know just a normal person but
everyone knows i mean come on this guy
the traveling wilburys you know just
that alone everybody knows the music you
just might not know it's yellow but
you've heard it in a million commercials
absolutely at some point it was like oh
yeah this is this is crazy catchy it's
going to be everywhere yeah and thimble
asst got me the new yellow record on
vinyl and it is [ __ ] great ok next up
Jay geils uh you know I'm not going to
deny on this
this band so one of the biggest records
in the 80s centerfold a lot like up
there at the time of IQ lewis and the
news sports yeah where these records
come out or hooting the Blowfish later
on let's say or orellana's Morissette
these records that absolutely grab
everyone yeah what's up at one of the
worst songs of all time those Jay geils
freeze frame freeze ray oh no I I
disagree with her oh please frame please
man i love that and then they had angel
in the center phone yep they had freeze
frame but you know a lot of people think
that this guy that the front man peter
wolf what well people in the 70s would
like fight you and stuff they thought
this guy was the best frontman of all
time over Steven Tyler and [ __ ] yeah I
mean there was actual like competition
and when I saw that the stones in 81 we
got a call let's grab it stones an 81 on
tattoo you they opened it all right they
[ __ ] he was giving him a run hey
what's going on here on the air who's
calling so Dean what's up Spicer what uh
Nate out of San out of Santa Rosa what's
up Santa Rosa Nate what's happening back
right how we doing boys we're talking um
we're talking Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
nominees today oh really uh [ __ ] who
dominated this year well it's quite a
few bands but we're going through them
right now you can google it but uh let's
just give you a one of the bands do you
think should be in journey yeah
absolutely okay journey come in this
journey come in new frontman no no no no
he doesn't get in no he doesn't get it
but he's singing the song as he got
wrote but what about way you can get him
because he hasn't been doing it for 25
years right that's four criteria well
you have to be on a recorded record and
yeah I think in the first 25 years or
something of the band yeah sure I don't
wanna work when rush was inducted that
was cool and well that was like 2013
yeah well there's a band like rush
and kiss that were never inducted a year
after year after year until they had
that kind of people vote thing and then
all sudden they just had a lot of hand
because and it's funny because I Eddie
and I were talking at a trunk and it was
like yeah that like kiss and because
there's so many fans that won't go like
spend twenty eight bucks to the rock and
roll hall of fame until kiss is in you
know and he's an interesting thing they
had their outfits and [ __ ] in there and
they weren't in the rocker [ __ ] crazy
is that done that before like exhibits
of yeah like yeah that's how to get
tickets I'll see you now yeah that's fun
what's happening man you got a question
today nice what I can't say I saw the
periscope and just wanted to check in
and really excited to see you guys see
you come up to the SF oh yeah you go
ahead and sell yeah I'm gonna try and
catch you on your closing night and and
on Friday all right [ __ ] yeah cool i'll
bring some i got these new guitar picks
made they're pretty [ __ ] cool oh yeah
yeah yeah i'll bring some and i'll give
you give him and that'll be cool man i'm
actually a NAPA right now with my girl
with a super is raining here and and
then or say a lot or like let's go to
fulfill my mapper so there's at the few
more flurries oh yes I'm Berkeley they
have a new location here in effing but I
cannot wipe out nearly run okay watch
the world series tonight yeah well you
know okay that's good it's just like I
don't it's gonna be I'm interested in
seeing the radiance because you know
Cubs we just get a murder the Indians
you know he's got he's gonna beat the
guys come on are you looking out good
these guys on I mean yeah that's Oxford
great this here in the Indians yeah I
think people don't realize I'm not
saying the Cubs won't land people don't
realize how good the Indians are because
they're in Cleveland and they don't have
LeBron on their team you mean and
everyone's just like no one paid
attention to him all year they also
dismantled the [ __ ] Blue Jays Blue
Jays were built to get to the World
Series again like it could be good you
know I wish that the Indians would come
out to an anthrax on crap
and quick actually the cup should come
out to that ok I'll cocky would that be
right cop or the India God closer just
comes out to bury my heart at wounded
knee it's just like oh no well there's
me so many good tons from you know the
Cubs and the Indian yeah it's gonna be
so much fun right on mega rare thanks
for calling in dead job let's be good
I'll see you in a few weeks there that's
right later we're all right so yeah Jay
geils you know it's interesting about
Jay geils before that [ __ ] big reckon
they were more kind of like a dirty
blues band hmm which is really crazy if
you listen to early Jay goes it's a lot
like early Bob Seger when he had that
smokin Opie's banner or whatever what's
totally like whoa who's this I think a
Bob Seger you want yeah you know that's
a lot like Jay geils now here's the band
that I think is a this band is
monumental to me jane's addiction yeah I
mean come on this is no one on this list
I think she'd go in faster than them and
and and some people think all too soon
you know the first time around but they
were so like so like you know everything
that whole thing they started the
lollapalooza seen the whole you know
alternative rock really starts with
Jane's Addiction you know yeah i think
the knock against them would be that
it's too soon we're too close to it and
we're going through the nostalgia
renaissance of that period yep and so
it's like Ed do we really love them
great but like do we really love them or
do we want to wait until we're not like
the 90s are cool again I just think that
that if you listen to those first two
records man you know it is just [ __ ]
smoking still right now comes on you
know it took that error man you know
rage against the machine uh James you
know ministry all that era of early 90s
is [ __ ] really original and kick ass
well it's great excuse me it's great
it's the
is like I think maybe people don't go
back far enough because it's fantastic
but it unfortunately led into limp
biscuit like that kind of [ __ ] that
maybe we'll end up liking more later
like I look like a beggar who actually
was pretty good but like I feel like so
rage and Janes and some of those bands
get lumped in with that like rap rock
like papa early Papa road right off like
that so like it's not that good but
don't blame them this would be opposite
of what you did at the beginning don't
blame a band for the [ __ ] they
influenced all right i mean you know the
thing is it's like jane's addiction to
me was just i remember when they first
came out people were actually saying
they were the new Zeppelin and i kind of
felt like that because they they kind of
had some you know like they were really
acid rock you know they're really kind
of psychedelic oh they were kind of that
some acoustica flavors and [ __ ] it was
all over the board and the singer was so
original sound crazy echoes and stuff
you know and the second record three
days is still one of the greatest songs
to come out of that era just a song
about quitting heroin ah next up Janet
Jackson I say no to Janet Jackson I
think she's phenomenal I don't I'll quit
saying this after this I mean she's not
rocking role she was my first concert um
she is hugely influential on rafts R&B
what modern soul Britney Spears all that
stash free like top country Taylor Swift
so I love Janet Jackson but if someone
says she doesn't belong in the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame I beg sure fine
whatever but I mean I Janet you know
it's miss Janice Dickinson mateys yeah
she's an icon to me it's not about you
know uh race or or style of music or
anything it's never about that to me
it's about um you know rock and roll to
me music to me is do you sing live but
she doesn't seem life you know what I
mean she can she has but her tours
aren't there though yeah I know but I'm
just saying I gotta have I got a lot of
people that sing live also did she write
in this
songs probably not pleasure principle
probably some dude you know she had that
guy Jimmy Jam and that that team so what
about what about what about element well
I'm eldon roadies songs and the other
guy wrote the that's what I'm saying so
like but you're getting him in and
you're looking at his piano and it's
like we don't do that no he wrote the
museum underwear okay Ernie red doors
look at what but still he wrote these
[ __ ] all these songs you know to mean
and that was a partnership and you're
both went in you know right but we got
another call but I mean man that guy you
know he sings and plays live hey how are
you man you're on the air who's calling
hey it's biggie from Connecticut how are
you man how's the weather that boat it's
[ __ ] stuck it's cold already there I
scraped the windows this one under the
car so oh I'm going to New York in a
couple weeks and I'm ready to check out
I've never have yet to been there this
year when it was cold you now took gonna
love New York City just falls in the
city too with our wounded [ __ ] man Wow
yeah hey listen I think I don't
understand how journey hasn't made it to
the Hall of Fame yet yeah argue that
late seventies early eighties one of the
biggest bands going not only that but
beyond the so many [ __ ] hits so many
hits and so great live i saw journey
many times and you know is it's exactly
and you know we could waste hours and
hours sitting here going how is this not
banned not in and that's always going to
be the conversation you know but when
you're looking at about 50 bands we can
look at like 50 bands from 76 let's say
sixty eight seven ish you know to 79 80
all those bands we could name right now
Boston journey Aerosmith Ted Nugent
earth wind and fire are the cars now
they're on a [ __ ] game they're on
again the cause have Amelia I saw the
cars they had so
many hits I couldn't go take a piss we
had no piss tracks it was one of those
great man I thought they were terrible
wife though well that's funny because
some people think they're totally boring
live and stuff but to me I didn't really
think about it because the music was so
loud and the songs were so good like
when it comes on it's just like on do
just like yeah it's like pushes you to
your Jack Maxwell tape commercials or
whatever you're like push yeah but you
know what I'm saying we could sit there
and say that over and over and it just
becomes a cliché but when you do look at
a band like journey I mean come on man
this bear hey don't not believe the i
live in hartford they sell off five
nights in a row at the super said are
there mg every year well you know on the
big record which was the the massive
record you know with faithfully and all
that the hits those guys they were doing
[ __ ] football fields man football
fields and they're still working right
now like right now with the with the
fake guy they sold out the staples man
you know what happened to keep he just
doesn't give a [ __ ] her no I think he's
gonna I think he's going to come back
but Steve Anna I think he has a lot of
emotional problems and stuff he had a
couple hip surgeries or something that
wiped him out and then I think his voice
got a little shot and and then he just
got lazy but he's saying last year with
the eels secret showed up at that and he
sounded [ __ ] great man he sounded
great Nicky maybe the whole phenomena
tional well that's what I know the fake
singer said he was hoping for he was
open to he goes I hope they get in so I
could see Steve Perry sing with him
again and that's [ __ ] cool of the guy
to say yeah they're one of the greatest
lost things I've ever seen it yeah cuz
last last year Chicago did that and
Peter Cetera was like I'll come back nah
she paid to me although to me I look at
it the same way as gnr what they should
have done gnr was got together and said
oh
right let's secretly play I'll walk out
and then at the end of the night we
announced the tour you know and man you
had a [ __ ] heads pop off if they do
that with Steve Perry he comes out he
just sings [ __ ] faithfully and wheel
in the sky or lights you know some other
side there's a lot of people that don't
know what a great thing with that guy
was you know that just overnight of them
no I saw Steve Perry on the first tour
that he was in the band Greg Raleigh
still in band at the time which I think
Greg Raleigh and him together when you
listen to that infinity record it is
unbelievable how great that record
another hole in my time in Monday well
you know and then Steve Perry comes in
the two voices oh man and they were
rocky fairies two solo albums so okay
yah and Neal Schon so [ __ ] underrated
this guy played in santana when he was
16 years old man the [ __ ] guy is a
key he wrote those songs man and most of
the time allegedly on a little a little
chilly wet head so wow I love that guy
and he can play the [ __ ] out of the
guitar all those guys are great players
man the whole band and they got the
original drummer back Steve Smith so
this is just cool [ __ ] man how much will
happen we'll see what happens but yeah
man thanks for calling it I'm gonna be
in New York in November come out to
shell oh it's out of the village again
yeah i'll be at the stand like november
16 through the 20th i'll try my damndest
to get down there man I'm with hook up
in New England so right thank you expect
swear Thank You Man litter thank you so
anyway yeah journey man wow that's cool
that he brought that up kraftwerk I just
talked about it kraftwerk 100% yeah you
know honey come on it's so [ __ ] cool
the dumb corny joke I've been sitting on
all episode I'll say it but please no
i'm not saying it as a joke yeah next
time you say kraftwerk i say i'm more of
a
services fan and thank you thank you I
always think Kraft Mac and Cheese oh
yeah I take that too oh that's the best
it's like you get the one piece that has
like didn't get mixed right to this kind
of powdery oh yeah just like coking it
on your gums like yeah I don't know i
think the kraft mac and cheese is so
[ __ ] great it's so funny how garbage
it is and you could eat it right now
with uh with like a bowl of soup and a
grilled cheese or something and just be
in heaven yep so far as a dad of two
young girls oh yeah the [ __ ] we're not
doing the craft I returned to like the
healthier Annie's or whatever but the
biggest the biggest lion mac and cheese
is when they call a box like family size
oh yeah it's not it's like it's dad
sighs like I'm like there's none for you
yeah we'll make two boxes move my shame
alone and that really changed over the
years to I notice it would get less and
less pasta in there I'd be like what's
going on here my favorite just [ __ ]
dirtbag meal I'd come home from school
I'd fire up some mac and cheese and then
I would get it all ready I'd put the
cheese in and everything and everything
and then I'd get a the bottle of pace
picante yeah pour it in there and I'd
make the [ __ ] spicy mac and cheese
yeah it's like a Kottam blinking with
the name of that's cauldrons out like
queso with salsa mixed in so [ __ ]
good man I've been out of Texas for too
long to not know what that's called but
it's the best all right next by an mc5
[ __ ] yeah just Detroit kick out the jams
[ __ ] yeah my knowledge of their
discography is so limited why would I
will defer to your jetta wait I can name
well no at the drive-in if you don't got
mc5 that's probably true and also you
know that whole era of like Iggy and the
Stooges and mc5 and and bad brains and
all that [ __ ] actual [ __ ] and mc5
kind of political raw kind of a way
dangerous for the time and just [ __ ]
a I mean groundbreaking you know and
definitely in let's see here we got next
up pearl jam of course yeah
the only reason I think pearl jam again
won't get in right now is that we're in
rose-colored glasses nostalgia like you
know they came out and played again and
toured again and they killed it and
everybody [ __ ] loves pearl jam again
they're gonna put him right in cuz he's
been so part of the raga raga every year
he does one of the inductees he's jams
with every one of those funds are edible
yeah there's no way he's the ambassador
of music yeah totally and you know what
[ __ ] he deserves to be in I mean you
know when you sell that many records you
know it's like and you write that many
songs and and they're out right now
selling out arenas no Mulder that many
lyrics you yet and not only that but
then he's on [ __ ] hunger strike you
know on temple of the dog and then you
know incredible yeah he's great remember
that weird five-year period where
everybody rock everybody hated Pearl Jam
yeah that's weird he'll say wait wheeler
was like yeah they suck it's like what
not the same [ __ ] is still great and
then like five azaria like yeah we were
John they are great it's a manly hates
him oh [ __ ] that bad huh weird you know
I mean here how do you deny uh 10 and vs
yeah it's incredible yeah it's crazy now
they were there was a little battle
there where the drummer wants to be
included on the ballot from the he
didn't play on 10 but he joined the band
because the drummer that played on 10
left the band to join Saturday Night
Live bad day yeah you know and then they
get [ __ ] you know Dave Abruzzi or
whatever and then he plays on the next
two and he's not in which house is weird
because he went out and did all that the
roadway any plate on my favorite pearl
jam versus hands down that's yeah I
don't I I need to look into the rules
that does seem that seems weird that
seems weird to me yeah it's like Gilby
Clarke got clown from gnr yeah I had him
on the show when it happened huh and he
preyed on two records and he did he was
you know he's in the band lot more
touring than izzy stradlin of course
he's not the original guy but he played
on records he toured with the band for
years and then everybody thinks that
it's like something with the inside with
the band like we don't want that or
whatever
who knows that maybe I could understand
but otherwise from the Hall of Fame's
perspective it's like what is it cost
them to put another dude on there like
what is it why not why not just include
everyone that played on the album that
you know meets the age requirement or
whatever especially if you're in the
band and the biggest era yeah yeah like
if the waterboy of a football team gets
a Super Bowl ring yeah if you play drums
and support of the biggest album on the
road like you were that guy you're
definitely in yeah it's weird but I
don't run the world steppenwolf a course
yeah that's that's when I'm like what
yeah are they not known i don't know i
mean magic carpet ride and and you know
like the vocals you know and just that
it's just a killer band man well they
stood out in an era where I think it was
hard to stand out like they sounded
unique without sounding different does
that make sense like they feeling with
their era but at the same time put their
own spin on it yeah [ __ ] great vocals
and then of course the cars like we're
saying I mean come on the cars are the
seventies new wave air its cars blondie
you know talking heads those are the
[ __ ] bands that were considered yeah
the new wave movement they mean they had
so many [ __ ] song are talking heads
in yeah they got to be in Oh get my
guess would be yes but I don't know yeah
yeah then Tupac I think so for sure uh
it is insane what he did in his
unfortunately short time here on this
earth I mean this guy is monumental how
many records he put out this guy was
just recording non-stop you know and I
hate to think of how much he apparently
there's still tons that hasn't come out
I finished and you crazy killing it yeah
some people think it's fake it's a guy
that sounds like I'm exact and just
going to the truck and records here's
another Tupac record yeah wait did he do
that one but man Tupac I mean you got a
liquid he did he's a background dancer
and digital underground and he's dying
to be a rapper he breaks free does a
couple records and just becomes the
biggest star going I mean
I still think California you know is one
of the one of the best jams going for
hip hop California love yeah it's so
great and they did the road warrior
video for it and it's gonna say then
that you are a little bias against multi
talented people because you're not going
to let Janet in right because she could
also dance no no I know she didn't solo
right all her stuff the way doctor was
like writing poetry but it's like come
on you gotta let Janet I'm gonna I'm
gonna from own teams in it listen I'm
not clowning on I'm not color I love the
retro record I think there are amazing
songs but Jimmy Jam and Terry Lewis were
the masterminds of that whole thing and
and look if she would have been out
there singing live and doing shows and
touring for years and years it's the
same thing with Michael Jackson when
they always say Michael Jackson against
Prince I always say Prince because the
guy toward all the time Michael would
play one song he would lip-sync it on a
TV show once every three years ago
Michael is the best ever and I just
found out recently never knew this but
he didn't even write some of my favorite
songs I like it a living off the wall on
that record he didn't write rock with
you or shake your body down to the
ground or [ __ ] um oh there's another
one I was like wow I didn't even know he
didn't write these songs cuz I always
thought he rode all the towns you well I
don't know about Michaels touring habits
but Janet put in the work I don't know
you probably just weren't plugged in but
like Rhythm Nation she toured her ass
off or Janet she toured her ass off for
control like G she put in the [ __ ]
road work I remain my beyoncé is right
now you might not be aware of it but she
is out there working her ass off I love
Janet I had a crush on her when I was
young I loved her but I remember
specifically which is funny somehow this
law didn't stick in but during the milli
vanilli and Janet Jackson era there was
this law that went through that said if
they were lip sync and they had to put
it on the ticket and for a little bit it
was on tickets i would say enhanced
vocal oh sure yeah and then
and I think then they realized everybody
was doing that yeah we just got to get
rid of this video yeah but I remember
that lon I could also be [ __ ] making
that up too if it was just one if it
didn't happen or they passed it or
whatever but it was really uh every time
I saw Janet Jackson she just wasn't
singing and I just need singing you know
I need that man and I can't go with the
dancing if she just sang I'd be like
yeah yeah let her in you know you know I
don't know it's like do you let britney
spears in not yet but yes yeah yeah [ __ ]
ever sent oh man I don't know I don't
know what yeah cool i'm down like a lot
of these young guys or you know not even
young anymore like I mean I don't know
if all of in sync gets in but Timberlake
certainly does well yeah Justin
Timberlake certainly does and then to
not have all the van think come in and
you know they were [ __ ] manufactured
now they were so insane with Backstreet
Boys they were so good at that thing
it's kind of like in my opinion it's
kind of like denying hitters in the
steroid era of baseball from being in
the Hall of well that's ridiculous i
guess they've proven repeat offender
guilty people then it's like we you
punish them and make them wait a few
years yeah but it's like that was the
game that's all [ __ ] that's all
rising music that guy knew they were
doing john-boy it wasn't illegal for the
first four or five years or whatever
right and then after the strike no one
was gone seen baseball and then the
[ __ ] home run bash brothers and all
that [ __ ] you know Sammy Sosa against
[ __ ] McGuire starts having it starts
putting butts in the seats and bud
seagulls not seeing anything and then
finally a wait a minute this is steroids
and it's like everybody got like Jeff
Kent and that dude on that guy that
played four million games in a row what
was his name I'll Ripken Cal Ripken
those are the only two guys that didn't
do junk no I I don't know Kalin I wanted
you know purchase name but I don't know
how you play that many games without a
little help well I don't
oh well no amphetamines early we're
legal sure yeah but that's where i put
Janet on Backstreet Boys and Britney
Spears is like I know it's a weird
analogy but it's like they were the best
at the game and how the game was played
yeah well we can get into sentimental
stuff and we can also get into eras just
like baseball that was an era of music
that uh drove butts in the seats and
sold records and kept music probably
alive yeah I can I can definitely agree
with that and I'm not some [ __ ]
buffoon over you're like no way man you
know what I mean but when I sit down and
think about Tupac yeah I think about a
guy who you know uh just all odds
against him yeah oh you know more in
city projects [ __ ] you know doesn't
know what to happen it just just wants
to be a rapper / you know what I mean
and and Rises out with [ __ ] hundreds
of songs and becomes a voice of hip-hop
that is like top five yeah you know you
got like biggie you got NWA you got a
snoop dogg you got to park these are
songs that are still played every
[ __ ] day yeah i'll be doing man so
i'm going to say something perhaps maybe
he's already in and I maybe its
controversial I don't want to get anyone
Killed but does suga get in as a
producer [ __ ] no I mean that guy's
[ __ ] hits yeah but I can hit I don't
know if he would hit and hit I think he
was just the money executive producer
you know yeah maybe here's something
crazy yes isn't in which is like has
that Paul so who wears no one yes yea
vote no and yes I if I saw this bag
right here but in this picture yes and
my son right now I'd be like Silver Lake
Baron is that jet yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that looks so [ __ ] cool compared
to how they sounded yeah I mean they're
just nerdy you know kind of prog rock
you know but look how they look it
looked like Pink Floyd R and Aaron yeah
one hundred percent so anyway it's
always fun to talk about the rock and
roll hall of fame because every you know
it does spark up so much great
conversation and what I love about it
and I
like I said I'm not these guys that are
like you're [ __ ] wrong I just love
anybody that is uh has enough passion to
care about it like no way man Janet
Jackson are you crazy she's got to be in
there okay cool you got some music
passion most people are like wow it was
rock and roll hall of fame you know
beyonce's the only want you know
whatever people just live in the moment
right and music it's just a soundtrack
to their Instagram selfies and stuff
well i think is going to be curious and
to go back again to the britney
Backstreet Boys era I think there's an
interesting thing there and part of it
is my own ignorance of the kind other
music that existed at the time but what
I think what also will make them a
shoo-in and also I think will help pop
punk when it comes time for its light to
get shine on it again is that if you
look at it wasn't as if brittany was out
at the same time that knew Aerosmith not
Aerosmith but like the next Aerosmith
was coming up so it's kind of like there
wasn't like this amazing other like
hardcore [ __ ] rock we're riding all
our own [ __ ] we're gonna be the big like
I know there are around that started
then yeah but they weren't like yeah I
mean you look at all that step through
that era like it's like when I [ __ ] on
the 90s music for a minute and then just
googled nineties rock hundred songs and
I was like well I'm an idiot yeah it's
all the stuff i love because you just
think 90s is like to me i think the
early early nineties i still think it's
like late it is that you know it just
seems like a blur and then I don't think
anything's happen until 2002 with the
strokes yeah yeah yes you said you can
just say blind melon and I think you win
that argument I thought it was like 90
didn't have anything they're just like
oh yeah yeah one melon like gone crazy
over blind melon all weekend to like
RiRi back on its so hard oh good it's
unbelievable how good this [ __ ] band
is man that guy well I saw him you know
alive twice but it saw him a few days
before he died and I talked about on the
podcast on Monday it still sticks with
me yeah it's just like what and now i'm
reading his lyrics like his lyrics on
this record soup which is the record no
one [ __ ] bought after the huge one
which I still understand but when I read
these you know mouthful of cavities
galaxy scraped toes across the floor
these lyrics are unbelievable and I know
how hard lyrics are to write and i'm
reading this guy i got this guy was a
genius yeah a [ __ ] genius man and
tortured yeah like yeah drugs aight that
man alive yeah it's hard it's hard but
yeah it i think it's easy to forget or
to allow yourself to become cynical with
certain errors or genres of music and
when you do dive in like 70s all seven
who's just disco [ __ ] and you're
like oh really oh yeah because i'm
pretty sure rancid had some amazing [ __ ]
coming out or whatever well the 70s has
the best music because you have disco
which I love you have new wave and punk
and you have you have rock acid rock
stone or rock [ __ ] you know just
classic rock now of course but i mean
the the mix of everything in that is Who
I am now as a human Leona mean like I
said you got sly and the family stone
and then you got [ __ ] Boston and then
you got the Bee Gees with the [ __ ]
saturday night fever soundtrack that is
an absolute masterpiece man that record
is insane and that film is insane that
is one thing i miss and maybe someone
listening will point out maybe this is
my own ignorance and it is happening and
i'm just not aware of it but i do miss
that masterpiece movie soundtrack album
yeah we don't get him anymore and maybe
the last one was a the latest fast and
the furious and it was a bunch of
different artists but it had like hits
now that would that one galaxy a movie
galaxy that what was it I don't which
one what's the movie guardians of the
galaxy that had a great sound yeah but
those were all established hit yeah yeah
I got your like new songs am I get
certain I feel I record it's like these
are here's the Bee Gees they go yo I
mean the Bee Gees was straight up badass
full kind of country band like Mike
Everly Brothers and early Eagles and
that kind of stuff and then on the
sudden talk about a band that [ __ ]
just you know reinvent
himself and writes these disco
masterpieces man yeah i mean how deep is
your love is insane credible and also
staying alive right intro with the feet
walking down the street I mean I got
goose bumps that movie hurts me yeah
it's earth that's my early love for New
York yeah yeah yeah i know i remember i
wanted i want to live up there and be in
the disco yeah yeah I was like twelve
man I hope disco dance my early thoughts
of New York or war is the Warriors of
course so that cause like I was it was
its older than I am but I was gonna like
the first like nicotine with my older
brother to watch the warrior so I'm like
you know give me open on the big kid no
you to get there I just did a photo
shoot there you know yeah you know Coney
Island cuz I just [ __ ] loved it so
much I I gotta your photo shoot here
male just [ __ ] that cyclone man and
it's still I talk about it over I know
everybody just gonna talk about the
cyclone and I can't get enough of that
goddamn ride man it's so dangerous crazy
I love it like not on the cyclone but I
think four people died in Australia yeah
like that [ __ ] is real dangerous yeah
it's not like i was reading today about
it there's no government like ordinances
on these rides so basically as long as
you say we're inspecting them you're all
good which is crazy yeah no thanks yeah
I ride them all the time I mean it's
like flying you also riding motorcycles
I know I doesn't Prius I think you can
see ya I've been trying to get Biddle
come here and I doubt to match map we
drive by it like probably 10 times a
year and we're like we gotta go there
next weekend and we never go it's just a
little too far away to make it a
spontaneous trip for me yeah like it's
that yes far enough away to be like ah
my problem is I've gone with celebrities
before we have that great [ __ ] just
don't wait in line right pass yeah and
once you do that you're like oh I don't
want to be in line with the [ __ ]
element yeah you know the [ __ ] just
the garbage people there man just oh
it's crazy yeah you know
used to go there and people just be
smoking cigs in the line yeah there's
like babies in strollers and they got
they got the cigarette down here right
by the baby's face like the cigarette is
right in the baby's face as soon as is
it's just right there and and the mom's
not gonna like do you mind they're just
like how long is this line I it's not it
is not a cheap place to go yeah but I do
not understand sometimes and I love
theme parks growing up it was the same
way of growing up they were never cheap
they were cheaper but like in real
dollars of the time they were never
cheap I just do not understand how some
other people get in there I got like
that's my job talk about the Warriors
yeah every [ __ ] theme park is like
the Warriors yeah it's like four
different groups coming out to play and
exciting and then oh I did the vid about
it I go Disney is 110 that's right now
to get in which means some people
shouldn't be in there yeah yeah and I
mean like what what are you do here you
got [ __ ] no teeth if you're in
[ __ ] line here yeah key in a fiction
face it's [ __ ] crazy yeah let's get
out of here done great to see you
likewise fun to be back yeah and what do
you got I I'm gonna be in Santa's ear
this weekend all weekend and if you're
there to see Russell Peters get there
early because i'm featuring can't wait
to do that and then next tuesday i will
be at The Comedy Store you can get a
tickets right now online Joey Diaz and I
coming in there to knock some new stuff
out and that for people that are
listening because podcasts are fluid
that is a November first yeah November
for ya and then when Steve Simmons
record come out I don't know but keep it
dude Steve Simone he's got a podcast
good times on all things comedy this guy
is incredible yeah whoever is in charge
of comedy specials and comedy anything's
give them all the Steve Simone and I'll
be I'll be okay with so yeah you heard a
preview of his new record today said it
was [ __ ] crate and maybe you want to
quit comedy yeah it's so good I don't
want to talk too high of it because I
don't know if I'm supposed to say
anything about it but sorry Steve it's
so good whatever right here you know we
know what's coming out it's so yeah it's
so it's so [ __ ] good and then
hopefully mine will be good november
15th in san diego and if you like geek
stuff
it's small right now but it's called at
least 20 more minutes every week plus a
few bonus episodes I wanted a podcast
we're like you can do with music with
like something new drops you can just
sit down and record so this is like when
Nintendo just announced a new consoles
like I got to talk about this somewhere
so i started this podcast it's at
patreon.com /christian spicer you can
just pay like a buck a month and it's at
least 20 minutes every week plus anytime
something new or hot and the geek world
drops I'll sit down and you know put my
thoughts put my thoughts on tape word
yeah monday if you like this shirt i'm
wearing if you're watching it i'm gonna
have the guy on the podcast who makes
the most amazing rock and roll shirts i
wear a medium I've ever [ __ ] I don't
know this is small I think you'd wear
small ok fine I'll take whatever you
look at right we're a small now i know
uh i don't want to say how incredible
you look beautiful ah alright guys
thanks for tuning leave the reviews you
fools and subscribe to let to be talk on
itunes love you guys trying to get
through a thousand reviews i'm at like
seven thirty three or something so keep
it go and see you guys